[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur France 24 notre invité aujourd'hui
est left punaumarev c'est un des
fondateurs de l'organisation de défense
des droits de l'Homme russe mémorial
tout juste récompensé par le prix Nobel
de la paix en compagnie du militant
biélorus à l'Est belliatski et de
l'organisation non gouvernementale
ukrainienne le centre pour les libertés
civiles lève pour nos marées l'animateur
aussi du mouvement pour les droits
humains il a quitté la Russie en juin
après avoir dénoncé la guerre en Ukraine
et il a fait une demande d'asile
politique ici en France tout d'abord une
réaction à ce prix Nobel
moi je suis un petit peu gêné par ce
prix Nobel ça fait longtemps que ça fait
un moment que je travaille pas
chez mémorial j'étais l'un des
fondateurs mais et deuxièmement je pense
que le prix Nobel aurait dû aller aux
gens qui se battent contre la guerre qui
sont dans les jaunes maintenant dans les
jaunes russes c'est Navalny Vladimir que
ramosa et Monsieur Yacine aussi ce sont
effectivement consciemment ils sont
allés en prison ils auraient pu partir
mais ces gens-là ont préféré la prison
pour se battre contre cette guerre alors
est-ce que vous pensez que peut-être le
prix Nobel n'a pas osé donner le prix
Nobel de la Paix à Alexis Navalny
je ne sais pas je peux pas comprendre ce
qui se passe dans le comité Nobel parce
que Navalny c'est un c'est une c'est un
personnage compliqué sur le plan
international et en Russie aussi moi je
l'a jamais été le fanatique de navani
politiquement on n'est pas toujours
d'accord mais à je trouve que c'est un
héros qui
au risque de sa vie
effectivement est en prison et mérite
largement ce prix alors évidemment tout
le monde veut savoir un petit peu ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur de la Russie en
ce moment surtout dans le domaine que
vous connaissez bien celui des droits de
l'homme alors on a souvent dit que
l'URSS sous Staline c'était l'État
totalitaire presque pure la Russie sous
Vladimir Poutine c'est quoi
tout ce qui se concerne la politique la
critique dans le domaine de la politique
je sais quoi si totalitaire c'est un
état quasi-totalité donc les lois qui la
adopté qu'il a fait adopter ressemble
beaucoup aux lois soviétiques toutes
critique contre la guerre qui correspond
pas à ce qu'il a été dit par les par le
ministre de la guerre
par les autres autorités militaires est
considéré un fake news ou à une
déclaration fake et donc il y a une
punition pénale qui est prévue pour ça
on sait très bien que eux ils mentent
tout le temps aussi et mais par contre
donc les gens risquent d'être
sanction administrativement et même
pénalement alors quand vous aviez fondé
mémorial c'était autour d'André Sakharov
c'était la pérestrocal à la chute du mur
de Berlin est-ce que vous pensiez qu'on
se retrouverait aujourd'hui en Russie
dans la situation que vous venez
d'écrire viens
même parce qu'à la fin des années 80
la population était prête pour la
Pérestroïka il y avait gorbachov
président de l'URSS qui aidait
à avancer à faire avancer la démocratie
aujourd'hui ça n'existe pas d'un côté on
a plus de liberté parce qu'il y a
internet vous pouvez critiquer beaucoup
sur internet mais l'humeur est très des
gens et
très déprimé donc à l'époque les gens
ont soutenu la Pérestroïka aujourd'hui
ils sont déprimés alors ils sont
déprimés ou est-ce qu'ils soutiennent la
guerre en Ukraine en silence peut-être
ou est-ce que au contraire il garde le
silence parce que ils sont dans leur
majorité compte c'est vrai que c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose
est-ce que Vladimir Poutine fait la
guerre sans le soutien du peuple russe
ou avec le soutien au moins tacite
cache moi je dirais que plus de 50 %
ne se tiennent pas la guerre moi j'ai
fait des tests j'ai fait des des
enquêtes par exemple la pétition que
nous avons fait contre la guerre dès le
premier jour un million 300 000
personnes ont signé cette pétition qu'on
avait
le principe qu'on avait organisé au
début de la guerre c'est beaucoup
c'est des gens
qui
sont sur Internet
etc mais je pense que réellement il y a
10 fois plus de 10 20 millions mais on a
fait des enquêtes on a vu qu'il y a plus
de 50 % qui sont contre la guerre mais
les représailles la répression est aussi
est tellement forte que les gens ont
peur alors on va parler de votre cas
parce que ça illustre vos propos donc
vous êtes en Russie dès le 24 février
vous lancez donc une pétition contre la
guerre vous déclarez à un journal
italien la Républica que vous avez peur
que Vladimir Poutine va emmener le monde
vers une troisième guerre peut-être une
guerre nucléaire et à ce moment-là vous
sentez tout de suite toutes sortes de
pression des autorités est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter ce qui vous est
arrivé
bien sûr c'est exactement ça avant la
guerre je savais que la guerre est
imminente alors que plusieurs pensées
que la guerre n'aurait pas lieu qu'elle
sera reportée à plus tard etc
et j'ai été arrêté
après le 24 on avait l'émission d'austes
la pluie donc cette émission j'ai été
assez émission et j'ai appelé tout le
monde venir au centre de Moscou pour
protester donc à peu près 5000 personnes
sont arrivées c'est pas beaucoup et
là-bas j'ai les gens étaient embarqués
par la police moi aussi après j'ai été
poursuivi
le des poursuites pénales ont été
annoncés contre moi ont été commencé
contre moi on m'a arrêté on m'a dit que
j'étais
rechercher au niveau national et j'ai
compris qu'il fallait que je parte moi
je suis j'ai pas l'âge de Navalny
si j'étais aussi jeune que nawali je
serai peut-être rester moi j'ai décidé
de partir en dehors des poursuites
pénales est-ce que vous avez eu des
intimidations presque physique on vous a
dit attention tu prends des risques avec
ta vie avec ta santé si tu continues à
faire ce que tu fais en Russie nous
vient pour taxe qu'elle vient de premier
être sûr à 100% est-ce qu'il cherchait à
me faire partir ou réellement il y avait
une des poursuites pénales il se peut
que
ils est juste essayé de me faire partir
mais je voulais pas vérifier s'il y
avait des poursuites pénales on m'a dit
des sources fiables m'ont dit qu'il y
avait une des poursuites pédales et que
j'allais être arrêté un certain jour
mais peut-être j'aurais pas emprisonné
parce que je suis trop vieux mais c'est
tout c'était pas clair donc j'ai décidé
de partir alors est-ce que ce ne serait
pas une stratégie de Vladimir Poutine
vous avez parlé de Ilia il aching qui
est aujourd'hui emprisonné et il a
déclaré que de ce point de vue Poutine
est peut-être plus malin que Staline
parce qu'à l'époque de l'URSS on
enfermait les gens les empêchait de
sortir alors que Poutine a tendance à
vouloir faire partir ce qui s'opposent à
lui parce que ça lui permet aussi de
dire regardez il vont manger dans la
main des Occidentaux en se réfugiant
chez eux c'est bien la preuve qu'il
faisait partie d'un complot
occidental contre la Russie
évident chaque opposant Poutine est
considéré comme agent de l'Occident
agent étranger
Poutine donc est en guerre contre
l'Occident contre presque le monde
entier donc chaque personne qui pense
que Poutine n'a pas raison est considéré
comme agent de l'Occident agent de
l'ennemi c'est très dangereux des
nouvelles lois ont été
promulguées donc caramorza peut prendre
jusqu'à 20 ans de prison parce qu'il
avait critiqué Poutine tout en étant à
l'étranger et la parole dont des
parlements de différents pays mais
c'était juste l'opinion personnelle de
karamuzza sur ce qui se passe dans le
pays mais maintenant il est considéré
comme agent de l'Occident qui est là
pour
parler de l'agenda occidental et
effectivement il menace directement la
sécurité de la Russie donc il est
considéré comme un espion
est-ce que vous pensez que cette guerre
en Ukraine c'est ce qui va perdre
Vladimir Poutine
spacieux
je me préparais bien à cette question et
j'ai je suis très content que vous me
l'avez posé un Poutine
tomber ou pas tomber en tout cas en ce
moment il est en train de perdre
on sait pas quel régime
serait après Poutine je pense que qui
est le plus de gens fassent de
l'agitation contre Poutine
et ici voilà en Occident je dis partout
que du temps de l'URSS il y avait une
la contre propagande
occidentale était très efficace
il y avait la propagande anti-communiste
et antisobiotique il y avait un récit
démocratique sur la démoc aussi
il y avait des récits des
informations très fiables concernant les
démocraties en Occident maintenant
l'Occident devrait faire la même chose
il faut il faut que
il faut il faut que ce soit
effectivement une chaîne d'infos ou une
radio qui expliquerait les valeurs
occidentales en fait je pense que les
valeurs occidentales sont les mêmes que
les valeurs russes si on disait ça tout
le temps sur une large population
pourrait s'imprégner de toutes ces idées
qui qui ressemblent pas du tout à ce que
raconte la propagande russe donc
rapidement en conclusion vous pensez que
on est à la fin de l'air Vladimir
Poutine
la fin de Poutine de l'époque en tout
cas de l'époque Poutine mais ce sera pas
la fin du fascisme en Russie il peut
transmettre
assez le pouvoir assez sbire à ses
compagnons et qui peuvent un petit peu à
adoucir éventuellement pour mener des
négociations
à négociation avec l'Occident mais le
fascisme va rester et il faut il faudra
continuer à combattre ce fascisme
d'être venu sur le plateau de France 24
merci à vous d'avoir regardé cet
entretien sur nos antennes restez-y pour
plus d'informations
[Musique]
toute l'actualité politique économique
culturelle et sociale d'une région en
mouvement
expressoriant le magazine du
Moyen-Orient présenté par Mériem amelal
à voir sur France 24 et France 24.com